ebenfalls für diskussionen in den
letzten stunden hat das verhalten von
friedrich merz gesorgt er hat jetzt
gesagt bei reuters dass er ihnen
angeboten habe wirtschaftsminister zu
werden wie ist das abgelaufen hier kann
mir ja nichts anbieten sondern habe mir
erst mal den parteitag
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass er ins
präsidium geht ich habe ihn gebeten es
war ein platz frei macht mit geh ins
präsidium und er hat das dann nicht
angenommen das ist sein gutes recht und
die frage ob es jetzt eine
kabinettsumbildung geht aber wie lief
das ab kam der trainer hat gesagt mensch
ich bleibe aber nur wenn ich minister
werde ein gutes gespräch gehabt und aus
guten gesprächen berichtet man nicht
aber er hat ja aus diesem gespräch und
berichtet ja er hat gesagt dass er
wirtschaftsminister werden würde habe
ich gelesen ich hätte ihnen im präsidium
mehr erwünscht haben sie mit der
kanzlerin darüber gesprochen
ich habe mit der kanzlerin der hat mir
natürlich im nachmittag gratuliert aber
da waren alle meldungen schon in der
welt und was dementi des kanzlers und
war der ministerposten denn aus ihrer
sicht die bedingung dass sich merz
irgendwie ins team ein reit was
präsidiale ein mann stellt auch nebenbei
einem neu gewählten vorsitzenden keine
bedingungen
ich hätte sich so aus als hätten wir im
märz ja ich hätte mir gewünscht dass er
mitmacht und ich glaube viele auch in
der partei hätten erhofft dass er in das
präsidium geht jetzt hat er das anders
entschieden und da habe ich allen
respekt vor und ich will sehen in
welcher form er mir weiter rat gibt ich
schätze ihn und ich schätze auch die
menschen die ihn gewählt haben und die
brauchen auch ein angebot in der cdu